TERRORIST GROUPS CALLING FOR
LONE WOLF ATTACKS.
THESE ARE THE FIGHTERS ISIS IS
PREPARING TO BE STONE COLD
KILLERS.
FEATURED IN A NEW TRAINING CAMP
VIDEO.
TONIGHT, A NEW AUDIOTAPE
THREATENING ATTACKS ON THE U.S.
HOMELAND IS DRAWING A STRONG
RESPONSE FROM WASHINGTON.
A U.S. OFFICIAL TELLS CNN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COUNTERTERRORISM
OFFICIALS ARE WORKING WITH
FOREIGN PARTNERS TO THWART THIS
THREAT.
A THREAT MADE BY A SENIOR ISIS
LEADER WHO, FOR THE FIRST TIME,
SPECIFICALLY CALLS FOR LONE WOLF
ATTACKS INSIDE WESTERN
COUNTRIES.
RIG THE ROADS WITH EXPLOSIVES
FOR THEM.
ATTACK THEIR BASES, RAID THEIR
HOMES.
CUT OFF THEIR HEADS.
DO NOT LET THEM FEEL SECURE.
REMOVE THEIR FAMILIES FROM THEIR
HOMES AND BLOW UP THEIR HOMES.
COULD THIS AUDIOTAPE ACTIVATE
ISIS INSIDE THE U.S. TO CONDUCT
A LONE WOLF ATTACK?
>> IT COULD.
AL QAEDA HAS TRIED IT BEFORE AND
KEEPS PUSHING THAT MESSAGE FOR
BIDS WITHIN THE UNITED STATES
AND EUROPEAN COUNTRIES TO ACT
OUT.
THE ISLAMIC STATE COULD BE
TRYING TO DO THE SAME THING.
>> Reporter: THE ISIS LEADER
SPECIFICALLY CALLS FOR ATTACKS
ON FRANCE AND AUSTRALIA.
JUST DAYS AGO, AUSTRALIAN
AUTHORITIES SAY THEY DISRUPTED
JUST SUCH AN ATTACK IN SIDNEY.
IN THE NEW TRAINING VIDEO, ISIS
IS REFINING ITS MILITARY TACTICS
AND SHOWS IT'S ABLE TO ATTRACT
MORE WESTERNERS.
>> THEY SEE THIS AS A SERIOUS
ORGANIZATION THAT REALLY WANTS
TO FIGHT, 234089 JUST TALK ABOUT
IT, TO BE A WARRIOR, AND THIS IS
PART AND PARCEL OF MAKING THAT
TRANSITION FROM BEING A CIVILIAN
TO BEING A WARRIOR IN THE MINDS
OF THESE RECRUITS.
>> Reporter: THIS IS ONE MAN WHO
COULD BE DRAWING THEM IN.
U.S. INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS SAY
THIS MAN, SEEN IN A RECENT
VIDEO, APPARENTLY EXECUTING
SYRIANS, COULD BE AN AMERICAN.
VOICE ANALYSIS IS UNDER WAY.
AND OFFICIALS TELL US THEY'RE
CONCERNED THIS COULD BE THE
FIRST TIME THEY'RE SEEING AN
AMERICAN IN POSITION OF APPARENT
AUTHORITY INSIDE ISIS.
FURTHER EVIDENCE OF WESTERNERS
BEING RECRUITED TO JOIN THE
JIHAD.
HOURS OF THAT ISIS SPOKESMAN
CALLED ON FOREIGN FIGHTERS TO
CARRY OUT ATTACKS IN THE U.S., A
SENIOR OFFICIAL WARNED THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IS NOT
PREPARED TO RESPOND TO SUCH